pierre laurent le secrétaire national du
parti communiste français est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous nous c'est-à-dire
lucile malandain de l' agence
france-presse et mickaël szames s de
public sénat
comme chaque semaine trois grandes
questions vous seront posées au cours de
cette émission première question
manuel valls peut-il aller jusqu'au bout
comme ils l'affirment sur la réforme du
marché du travail il rejette les
critiques des conservateurs donc comme
vous ancré dit-il dans le 19ème siècle
deuxième question votre divorce avec
jean luc mélenchon est il consommé des
bisbilles en effet vous êtes passé à la
rupture nette et franche sur la primaire
de la gauche
alors est ce également la fin du front
de gauche déjà fortement divisé et
secoué lors des dernières régionales
enfin troisième question que
réclamez-vous à l'union européenne
effectivement de pierre laurent vous
demandera de vous mettre dans la peau
d'un david cameron si vous y parvenez
non pas sur le plan idéologique en tous
les cas la salle et des opéras tolga tu
as peut-être de la manière d' exiger un
certain nombre de choses à l'union
européenne
première question donc manuel valls eu
droit dans ses bottes convaincu de la
nécessité de réformer le marché du
travail malgré les oppositions de plus
en plus nombreuses cette pétition qui
recueille de plus en plus de signatures
on écoute le premier ministre qui
répondait ce matin à un auditeur chef
d'entreprise prénommé laurent quand on
assume les responsabilités il faut aller
jusqu'au bout alors bien sûr laurent va
y avoir des discussions et les
partenaires sociaux et au parlement mais
notre définition du licenciement
économique comme le fait qu'on lève les
freins à l'embauché en réformant le
barème des indemnités prud'homale
ces deux éléments qui sont fondamentaux
pour les entreprises laurent j'irai
jusqu'au bout
alors qu'hier leur rancoeur et pandev os
qu'il pourra aller jusqu'au bout selon
vous ben je ne le souhaite pas parce que
tout le discours de manuel valls repose
sur un mensonge qui consiste à dire si
on met à bas le code du travail on va on
va embaucher davantage on va créer des
emplois
or il faudra il a dit qu'il fallait
qu'ils
il devrait convaincre mais il a intérêt
à affûter ses arguments
parce que faudra nous expliquer comment
par exemple parce que ça fait partie du
projet de loi en faisant voler en éclats
tous qui encadre le temps de travail
donc en faisant travailler davantage
ceux qui ont un emploi puisque l'on va
on va permettre dans le projet loi
d'aller jusqu'à quarante six heures par
semaine pendant 16 semaines consécutives
est ce qu'avec ça on va créer des
emplois alors qu'il ya déjà 5 millions
de chômeurs dans le pays
et beaucoup de jeunes qui sont en
formation et qui vont entrer sur le
marché du travail va vous de la soirée
étaient parvenus s'était pas qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout mais concrètement vous et
est ce que vous appelez à la riposte et
sous quelle forme
j'attends d'abord parce que c'est les
organisations syndicales qui sont en
première ligne dans cette dans cette
bataille elles sont elles sont en ce
moment même en réunion si elles prennent
des décisions d'actions nous serons nous
serons derrière les organisations
syndicales et moi j'appelle
effectivement j'ai moi même signé un
appel qui fait partie des appels qui
circule sur internet j'appelle d'ores et
déjà de toute façon à la mobilisation
sous toutes ses formes est déjà une
bataille d'explication parce qu'il faut
démontrer les mensonges qui sont
derrière le disney abandonné syndicats
vous avez vu il ya un fait important
effectivement ils sont ce soir tous
réunis à la cgt avec avec la cfdt
vous espérez un front uni des syndicats
on n'a pas vu ça depuis longtemps bien
sûr que je l'espère parce qu'on a on a
besoin d'unité et ce qui est frappant
depuis la publication de l'avant projet
de loi c'est l'ampleur de la
protestation en quelques jours des
pétitions en ligne qui sont couvertes de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
signatures et des réactions d'hostilité
ou de mécontentement qui balaye très
très très large
au point que les seules encouragements
que j'ai entendu ces derniers jours
viennent uniquement deux du medef du
medef et de certains secteurs de la
droite puisque eric woerth a dit qu' il
aurait pu écrire le projet de loi donc
c'est la mairie on dit aujourd'hui qu'il
espère que le texte ira jusqu'à son
terme mais bien sûr puisque c'est c'est
en toutes lettres dans ce projet de loi
ce que
réclame le medef et la droite depuis des
années donc eu évidemment vont pousser
et même peut-être faire de la surenchère
alors vous vous continuez l'efficacité
de ces mesures donc cela pour le cos et
c'est ce que prétend le gouvernement
l'exécutif et pierre laurent qui veut
aussi faire de la pédagogie et qui veut
tordre le cou à certains mensonges ainsi
l'exécutif rappelle que le texte
s'inspire tout de même des propositions
de robert badinter tels que les grandes
mesures sociales sont maintenus il ya
toujours par exemple une durée du
travail le contrat de travail ne change
pas non mais pas du tout justement on se
sert du texte qui a été écrit par robert
badinter et quelques autres magistrats
pour soi-disant affirmé des grands
principes qui sera en préambule de la
loi mais tous les articles qui figurent
dans ce préambule c'est à chaque fois on
garantit tel principe mais il faudra que
ce soit sauf dérogations prévues par la
loi
or précisément tout le projet de loi qui
est derrière c'est un projet de loi qui
vident de leurs contenus tous les
principes qui sont affirmé manuel valls
lui sert que de que pour un espèce de
paravent pour cacher la réalité du
projet de loi alors l'une des réalités
de ce projet de loi alors que vous avez
peut-être pour le contester mais c'est
ce que met aussi en avant manuel valls
et que rien ne sera décidé sans l'accord
des salariés équipes qui devront voter
mais pas des scrutins sous l'égide de se
dérouler ce qu'on veut pas du tout pas
du tout justement elle s'est encore à
jour cédant à faire absolument sur cette
affaire nos consultations des salariés
il a fallu se battre pendant des années
pour faire reconnaître une chose
importante c'est qu'un accord dans une
entreprise ne peut rentrer en vigueur
que s'il n'est pas contraire au code du
travail
premièrement et deuxièmement que s'ils
recueillent un avis majoritaire des
organisations syndicales
ces deux garanties la vole en éclats
avec le projet de loi puisque dans le
premier cas on prévoit dans le projet de
loi des contrats
des accords d'entreprise qui pourrait
s'imposer se substituer au code du
travail
donc d accord dérogatoire au code du
travail que par ailleurs en ville de son
contenu et deuxièmement en cas
d'opposition majoritaire des
organisations syndicales
on donne la possibilité aux syndicats
minoritaires de réclamer un référendum
des salariés
c'est à dire que tous les syndicats sont
fait élire que les indications assez
minoritaire a sécoué représentatifs dans
les entreprises contournant leur donne
la possibilité de consulter tous les
angles variés jeu c'est important quand
même de comprendre que la disposition a
été introduite pour contourner les
accords majoritaires ou le non accord
majoritaire et d'ailleurs vous savez
comment cette affaire est apparu c'est
le pdg de la fnac
ça a été raconté dans la presse et il
n'a pas démenti le pdg de la fnac qui
racontait partout que les salariés
voulaient travailler le dimanche
en vérité n'a pas obtenu le soutien des
salariés déjà complètement la ministre
du travail sa cause en disant il faut
trouver un moyen de déroger à cette
situation et c'est comme ça que cet
article a été en trouver même dans
lequel on peut écouter les chefs
d'entreprises aussi qu'est ce que vous
entendez bien sûr a besoin de bras des
emplois mais bien sûr qu'il faut aussi
écouter les chefs d'entreprise et tous
les acteurs de l'entreprise et moi j'ai
le souci justement du développement de
l'emploi et du développement de nos
entreprises
mais je pense que dans la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et tout ce qui
s'est fait depuis des années le montre
c'est que plus on fragilise les salariés
c'est à dire le travail et la qualité du
travail et bien plus finalement on
dégrade l'emploi au rang ce qui arrive à
avoir un emploi de plus en plus
corvéables et précaires et on ne permet
pas à tous les autres d'entrer sur le
marché du travail donc si on veut parler
créations d'emplois alors parlons
d'investissement par l'aude et des
moyens publics que nous mettrons pas
dans l'investissement dans les grands
travaux dans le logement dans les
transports dont là on le ferroviaire
dans les transports urbains
parlons de ces chants tirés et emmanuel
valls rétorqué l'autre jour en alsace ce
tiers d'ailleurs que c'est en renvoyant
ses détracteurs 19e siècle
on sentait mais la soneb les fous de la
charité l'hôpital qui se fout de la
charité mais parce que précisément si on
appliquait si on votait par malheur le
projet de loi n conneries alors là c'est
un retour sur tout ce qui a été
construit au fil des décennies pour
organiser une protection collective des
salariés devant les risques de la
précarité et du chômage et on cette
situation non c'est dans ces temps de
crise très dure
alors qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres
officiels le rapport de la fondation
abbé pierre la montre et on a atteint
maintenant 9 millions de gens en france
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté et parmi eux de très nombreuses
personnes qui ont un travail mais un
travail qui à temps partiel un travail
précaire qui ne permet pas de vivre
eh bien on va ouvrir les vannes à une
précarité qui est déjà galopante et qui
va tirer le pays vers le bas et non pas
le sortir alors il ya d'autres mots qui
sont utilisés par exemple jean marie le
guen qui est en charge des relations
avec le avec le parlement dit fustige
lui vous avez peut-être encore là vous
sentir visés et répondre il fustige les
grincheux les esprits chagrins
oui mais tout ça c'est des formules il
faut parler de la réalité la loi parce
que le discours qui consiste à nous
seriner à chaque fois que parce qu'on
met un projet de loi sur la table qui
l'a fait reculer les droits des salariés
ben on est moderne parce que c'est vers
ça que le monde évolue et bien moi j'ai
une autre conception de l'avenir je
pense que le 21e siècle doit être au
contraire un siècle où on se repose la
question du progrès social du commun
dans une société qui a été mondialisé
qui vit différemment mais qui justement
devrait nous conduire à nous poser
davantage le problème de la coopération
si on laisse le monde évoluer vers un
monde d'hyper concurrence telle qu on la
construit jusque-là dans la
mondialisation actuelle ça aboutit à
quoi a jeté les travailleurs les uns
contre les autres a jeté les peuples les
uns contre les autres a jeté les
migrants qui fuient la misère contre des
gens qui vivent déjà difficilement dans
les différents pays européens
qu'est ce que c'est que ce monde qu'on
essaye de nous
andres soi-disant comme un monde moderne
c'est un monde de chaos et un monde qui
va conduire ils comptent pas seulement
la guerre économique mais parfois même à
la guerre tout court
alors moi je pense que si on veut penser
avec un peu de modernité le monde
eh bien il faut au contraire remettre à
l'ordre du jour le progrès humain et
lagarde manuel valls a tout faux en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet là mais c'est
malheureusement une malheureusement son
cas sur à peu près tous les sujets sur
tous les sujets il a tôt fait de blessé
mais voudrait celui-là particulièrement
est un sujet très grave et c'est pour ça
que ça soulève un tel émoi dans le pays
je l'espère beaucoup de mobilisation il
a effectivement tout faux sur toute la
ligne car je savais ce que vous voyez
avec ce texte qu'elle portait donc par
myriam el khomri est ce que voyait
naître une nouvelle fracture politique
dans ce pays qui va bien au delà celle
des frondeurs par exemple des la
fracture est consommée
la fracture entre ses tics cette petite
équipe gouvernementale qui a fait sortir
petit à petit tous les ministres mais là
il y en a d'autres qui jouent en jeu par
le moment là qu'il y en a parlé d'un
élargissement ou non mais ça n'est pas
un élargissement c'est un gouvernement
qui n'a fait depuis cinq ans qu'une
seule chose c'est se rétrécir petit à
petit et qui a dû sortir de ce
gouvernement tout ce qui m était une
voix un peu différente et qui pourtant
pendant les premières années ont essayé
de s'accrocher et de soutenir le
gouvernement et il y en a aujourd'hui un
petit clan gouvernementale qui persiste
sur une ligne qui est rejeté par en
parler maintenant un clan oui un clan
gouvernementale autour de françois
hollande avec quelques ministres qui qui
qui sont restés dans le soutien au tour
de manuel valls
mais les forces vives sociale et les
forces vives de la gohelle agences sont
ailleurs maîtrisait mal le gouvernement
nous ne sommes plus gouvernée par la
gauche nous sommes gouvernés
alors une petite équipe autour de
hollande et de valls qui mène une
politique lot et kiwis et qui n'a plus
rien à voir avec les électeurs de gauche
qui avait porté ce pouvoir alors le
débat est quand même ouvert a dit le
premier ministre et ex
il a dit que le texte allait être
débattue mais bien sûr le parlement
variable a joué son rôle
et si le gouvernement il va s'en occuper
et que le parlement puisse jouer ce rôle
parce que évidemment tout le monde est
revenu en arrière très vite sur l'idée
du 49-3 mais la simple idée que ça ait
pu traverser la tête de la ministre en
charge du texte de parler de ça avant
même qu'on connaisse le contenu du texte
entre quoi en dit long sur la confiance
quand même qu'ils ont dans les
parlementaires de leurs deux enfants il
n'y a pas de majorité je leur propre
part vous êtes convaincus vous aussi qui
a pas de majorité
peut-être sur ce texte aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucune majorité de maires sur ce
texte y incarne ici à 49,3 la censure si
les administrés s'il est adopté ce texte
il est
ça veut dire qu'il sera adopté avec des
doigts de droite c'est d'ores et déjà
sur ça et si le gouvernement fait appel
aux 49 3 qu'est ce que vous faites vous
comme il est bien moi je proposerai à
l'ensemble des parlementaires de gauche
effectivement nouveauté une censure on
voterait la sensuelle je dis je le
proposerai puisque nous n'avons pas les
moyens moyens de déposer une motion sont
les bienvenus sommes pas suffisamment
donc je proposerai à des parlementaires
à ce moment-là de gauche de gauche qui
ce qui serait opposé à cela de déposer
on serait une censure alors vous
utilisez des mots forts depuis le début
de cette émission carré on vous parlait
d'un clan qui gouverne ce pays autour du
président de la république et qui n'est
pas de gauche et on va écouter françois
lang justement il n'a pas pu dire qu'il
était de gauche l'autre soir sur france
inter il était interrogé par nicolas
demorand
mais êtes vous encore de gauche françois
hollande su président de réplique je
suis revenu je reprends tous les
français m et j'évoquerai mon parcours
ma vie mon engagement
mes choix sont toujours ceux qui
permettent de respecter l'égalité la
dignité humaine et le progrès mais vous
n'avez même si je veux faire des choix
de gauche aujourd'hui et je toute ma vie
est une vie d'un homme qui s'est engagé
à la gauche là il rêve votre vie en 2012
et je suis devenu président de la
république je suis je suis toujours
engagé comme je l'étais mais je ne suis
plus un militant jeudi cet extrait
dit où le guide y tout dans la situation
actuelle il n'arrive pas à dire à dire
je suis de gauche comme si le fait
d'être gauche de gauche était un
handicap pour représenter la france et
les français
mais il se veut le président de tous les
français est bien sûr hors mais ça c'est
la fonction qui l'obligé normal ça
n'empêche pas là mais on peut on peut
assumer cette fonction est assumée
assumer ses convictions
d'autant que moi je considère que les
valeurs de gauche sont des valeurs qui
ont construit la devise républicaine
depuis la révolution française
donc elles quelles difficultés il y
aurait affirmé à cerner ses convictions
commencé malheureusement si je puis dire
extrêmement cet extrait malheureusement
extrêmement révélateur de la situation
dans laquelle on trouve alors comment
est ce que vous comprenez le pari d'une
certaine manière de françois hollande
peut-il être espérer être réélu en 2017
si ils se coupent de la gauche
si l'on suit votre démonstration mais je
long mais je pense que et je crois que
nous allons parler par la suite je pense
que justement il ne peut pas être le
représentant de la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle il est dit et si l'on
attendait et s'ils prétendent est l'être
eh bien il risquerait de conduire la
gauche à un échec majeur où il ne les
aime pas il ne doit pas se représenter
moi je crois qu'il ne doit pas être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle au
nom de la gauche il ne peut pas l'être
on se retrouvera dans une situation
indéniable celui qui prétend représenter
la gauche devrait porter pendant toute
la campagne
la déchéance de nationalité le
dynamitage du code du travail enfin on
sait ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
compréhensible pour pour personne pour
personne de ceux qui ont qui ont voulu
porter la gauche vous le ramener à un
rôle de candidate figuration il a fait
des choix politiques tous pendant tout
le quinquennat
donc vous les cv d'escalier dit la fed
et il a fait des choix politiques qui
ont été progressivement et de plus en
plus fortement à l'encontre de ce qui
était attendu
bien il n'a obtenu ni résultats en
matière de lutte contre le chômage ou le
progrès social il n'a pas fait avancer
ski ski ski et les skis sont les grands
principes d'égalité
pour le pays il n'a pas porté là
fortement la voix de la france en europe
pour faire évoluer faire c'est les
disqualifier sur tous les terrains donc
je pense je l' ai déjà dit de très
nombreuses fois il est effectivement
disqualifié et il va et il pourrait si
on le laisse si on laissait faire nous
conduire à l'élimination pure et simple
de la gauche au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est à dire
on peut au risque de se retrouver dans
un scénario qui est celui que nous
venons de vivre dans plusieurs grandes
régions françaises
et moi je ne veux pour art aucun prix de
ce scénario et je cherche et cela selon
alan dale prêt à venir on va en parler
dans 1 à 5 tout petit d'interdire
question est est ce que jean luc
mélenchon avait raison de dire que
françois hollande était pire que nicolas
sarkozy à vous écouter la réponse est
oui j'ai dit jamais vos jeunes en jeu je
n'emploie pas cette forme a pour une
raison très simple vous maintenant on a
des limites a pour une raison très très
simple mais c'est pas que nous portons
parce que sur cette question je suis
d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon sur
l'appréciation que nous portons sur le
bilan gouvernemental mais je n'emploie
pas cette formule pour une raison simple
c'est que je suis certain que si nicolas
sarkozy revient comme président de la
république puis il en rajoutera on va là
vous êtes à avrillé d'accord avec
l'exécuteur combat et même je crois pas
oui en matière d'aidé record sial
l'exécutive - genève un travail
intérieur n'ai pas envie de préparer une
élection présidentielle pour choisir
entre le pire et le moindre pas grave
allez deuxième question je peux avoir un
peu plus d'ambition ça on politique
deuxième question elle veut donc nous
porter vers la primaire de la gauche et
des écologistes que vous défendez avec
cette question que vient vous posez
lucile malandain de l' agence
france-presse
votre divorce avec jean luc mélenchon
est il consommé la primaire de gauche et
des écologistes donc vous divise en
écoute celui qui s'est déclaré candidat
en solo et qui vous fait la leçon c'est
le jeu de la toute la direction du parti
comme une quelques années les enfants
tout cas certains violemment me tire
dessus à vue depuis que j'ai proposé ma
candidature je n'ai pas reçu une balle
venant du camp socialiste ou ou de la
droite etc
je n'en ai reçu exclusivement que d'une
poignée d'un quarteron de dirigeants qui
a toutes circonstances qu'on revienne
sur les mêmes mots alors premièrement
pierre laurent ne m'avait jamais parlé
de son intention d'aller dans les
primaires ni aux coordinations qui ont
lieu tous les lundis
c'est son bras droit monsieur olivier
dartigolles qui a annoncé à la radio que
le front de gauche était cliniquement
mort pierre a dit que pour à l'heure
actuelle il n'était pas candidat
bref nous étions repartis pour la
carabistouilles illisible habituel je
veux je veux pas je sais je sais pas
donc moi je dis jeu j'attends que pierre
les fini de jouer sa partie avec ses
nouveaux amis de la primaire et un jour
il reviendra à la raison et comprendra
qu'il est impossible de faire équipe
avec françois hollande
ces suppôts et les autres organisateurs
de la primaire car tenez vous bien sûr
40 personnes qui signent pour la paix la
primaire il y en a 38 qui étaient contre
nous en 2012 on qu'on peut prendre
meilleur conseil que près de gens qui
nous ont toujours combattu alors le film
à l'envers avec nos bons soirs alors la
question donc alors jean-luc mélenchon
vous demande de cesser de jouer 2
revenir à la raison alors le divorce
consommé cette fois non mais ça n'est
absolument pas la question je n'ai pas
de commentaire à faire sur l'extrait
convient entendre parce que moi c'est un
ton que je n'emploie pas que je
n'emploie pas de manière générale et
encore moins avec avec des des amis avec
qui j'ai mené la dernière campagne
présidentielle voulait reprocher ou non
mais parce que j'ai envie une
qualificatif qui sont qui pourrait
envenimer la situation ça n'est absolu
la question du divorce comme vous dites
ou pas entre jean luc mélenchon n'est
absolument pas la question il y à une
discussion sérieuse à avoir et que nous
avons effectivement nous n'avons pas le
même avis sur cette question c'est que
les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
la politique gouvernementale
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas seulement
front gauche avec jean-luc mélenchon et
moi même maladie sont ils sont dans
toute la gauche ils sont chez les
écologistes et ils sont dans une part
grandissante du parti socialiste est ce
que nous essayons de construire ensemble
une candide un projet et une candidature
à l'élection présidentielle pour éviter
l'élimination de la gauche est ce que
nous essayons faire ça moi je dis que il
faut tout faire pour essayer cela voilà
et que 1 pour le faire la meilleure
manière de commencer c'est pas que le
front de gauche déclare sa candidature
et dire à tout le monde vous vous
ralliez à notre espèce et le front de
gauche qui déclare sa candidature c'est
jean luc mélenchon candidat du front de
gauche puisque lui il a été le candidat
du front de gauche avec jean-luc
marchand peut pas dire qu'il part avec
le parti communiste
non mais c'est certain que cette
déclaration de candidature s'est faite
sans consultation sans consultation du
la news en partie au parti communiste
nous l'avons dit pas ou pas du tout pour
poly peau limitées ou pour tirer des
balles
d'argent que mélenchon cd démo qui sont
totalement excessif mais tout simplement
pour que chacun le sache
parce que ça fait partie de la réalité
et du débat politique
je répète la question c'est ce n'est pas
celle là la question et c'est une
question que moi j'adresse aussi un jean
luc mélenchon en lui disant il est
possible de revenir ensemble dans ce
travail collectif c'est une question que
je partage avec d'autres offrants gauche
parce que le parti communiste n'est pas
le seul à avoir des interrogations sur
cette candidature en solo de jean luc
mélenchon dont le front gauche et
ensemble nous essayons de dire essayons
plutôt de lancer des passerelles jean
luc mélenchon dit une chose curieuse il
dit il dit dans l'appel de ceux qui ont
lancé un appel à la primaire il y à 38
personnes qui avaient voté françois
hollande au premier tour mais
précisément c'est quelle est la
situation c'est que l'immense masse de
ceux qui ont voté françois hollande au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle envie d'un autre choix
alors est ce que nous nous essayons avec
ces forces là de construire une
candidature ou pas si nous ne le faisons
pas ce que je pense je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que jean luc mélenchon
pourrait revenir dans un processus
collectif renoncé à se présenter ce que
s'ils se lève voir si cela met la
pression sur lui quand c'est
sérieusement oui je pense que s'ils se
lève une dynamique citoyenne autour de
cette affaire ce qui n'est pas gagné
parce que évidemment si on présente le
débat que nous avons comme comme vous le
faites un peu la commune histoire de de
tambouille politicienne c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va intéresser les gens et ça
les gens n'ont absolument pas envie de
ça et ils ont mille fois raison moi ce
que je veux et c'est ce que j'ai proposé
d'ailleurs à ceux qui veulent une
primaire c'est que la première chose que
nous fassions cela n'est pas de nous
mettre d'accord sur une liste de
candidats c'est qu'on organise dans tout
le pays pas deux trois débats des
centaines des milliers de déballer plus
le plus proche possible et qu'on invite
tous les citoyens à discuter de la
situation dans laquelle on est comment
est ce qu'on va sortir de cette
situation et éviter le piège d'une
élection présidentielle on va nous dire
vous avez le choix entre la droite le
front national et une candidature qui
est celle du président de la république
dont jean luc mélenchon va vous
rétorquer
il a déjà 60 de 1000 signatures des
groupes d'action qu'il y ait des gens
aux citoyens et j'entends c'est à dire
hors parti hors appareils mais qu'il y
ait des gens qui soutiennent jean luc
mélenchon c'est bien normal puisque nous
avons ensemble fait campagne et 4
millions de personnes ont voté pour le
front gauche
ce que je dis moi c'est que même avec
les forces que nous avons accumulée dans
le front de gauche
elles ne sont pas suffisantes
aujourd'hui à relever le défi qui est
devant nous en 2017
et comme il y a des gens dans les autres
familles de la gauche qui sont
disponibles pour une construction
collective et qui eux aussi veulent un
autre projet une autre candidature que
celle de françois hollande
ça vaut le coup d'essayer de construire
ça et moi je dis dans les mois qui
viennent
consacrons ensemble d énergie à
construire ça on me dit ça va peut-être
pas marché
c'est sûr si on n'essaye pas ça va pas
marcher mais moi je dis si on essaye il
ya une chance que ça réussisse parce que
je suis sûr que cette construction peut
aller au devant d'une très gras leur
désir d'unité de ces gens et qu'ils ne
veulent pas vivre une nouvelle alors à
propos de cette primaire de gauche sinon
pas de chez paris maire de saint jean
luc mélenchon a argumenté en disant
qu'il n'en voulait pas parce qu'elle ne
peut pas participer à une compétition
dont pourrait sortir vainqueur françois
hollande on est bien d'accord
vous même vous avez critiqué françois
hollande a fait durement depuis le début
de cette émission permet ainsi donc
françois hollande est légitimée par
cette primaire vous allez vous ranger
derrière le chef de l'état sortant est
le présage des rafales baradat mais oui
mais tu as écouté ses extraordinaires la
manière dont on a de retourner les
choses moi je pose une question simple
qui est est-ce qu'on s'engage dans un
processus collectif pour essayer de
construire ça avec des gens qui veulent
éviter la politique gouvernementale
actuelle et sa règle que vous n'avez
rien contre le fait après françois
hollande soit 20 07 non mais attendez
manuel valls et françois hollande parce
qu'on pose souvent la question on leur a
posé la question de la primaire vous
connaissez la réponse
manuel valls a dit qu'il n'en voulait
pas et qu'il était hors de question de
participer à une primaire françois
hollande a été interrogé deux fois sur
la question il a refusé de répondre et à
moi le secrétaire national du parti
communiste qui pensent qu'il faut un
autre candidat
on va me demander demain
être à genoux pour dire non il faut
absolument françois hollande soit
candidats dans une primaire mais on se
moque de qui moi je dis je dis c'est que
pour le moment ce qu'il faut faire c'est
organiser cette primaire en donnant la
parole aux citoyens qui veulent autre
chose qu'il faut commencer par là qu'il
faut faire émerger un socle d'engagement
commun qui serait le point d'entrer dans
la primaire par exemple on dirait on va
s'occuper de telles questions de telles
questions de telles questions c'est sur
ça que doit organiser le débat parce que
c'est une aux exigences citoyennes que
vous soyez et dénis par jean luc
mélenchon ni par manuel valls qui est
chacun dans leur dans leur genre est
dans leur camp dit ce que la gauche et
irréconciliables et que cette ville à
gauche la gauche chez qui la gauche
moi je pense que c'est pas manuel valls
qui va me donner des leçons de gauche la
gauche et des gens que je croise tous
les jours sur le terrain
certains ont voté jean luc mélenchon
comme moi en 2012
d'autres vont voter françois hollande au
premier tour notre voter eva joly et on
me dit ces gens sont irréconciliables
mais non ils ne sont pas
irréconciliables
parce que figurez vous que quand il ya
trois cent mille personnes en trois
jours qui signent la pétition en ligne
sur le code du travail
et bien moi je suis sûr que parmi eux il
ya des gens qui ont voté hollande il ya
des gens qu'on était mélenchon il ya des
gens qui ont voté eva joly ou d'autres
candidats et donc les gens de gauche ne
sont pas irréconciliables et même la
question c'est quelle il se met à
nouveau ensemble pour éviter le piège
dans lequel on veut nous enfermer
alors il ya une personnalité à gauche
qui ne dépas non à la primaire à gauche
y compris avec françois hollande enfin
il aimait des conditions c'est jean
christophe cambadélis qui est tout à
fait récemment sur public sénat dans
territoires ddt info évoquait justement
vos bizzbee à gauche sur cette primaire
en les côtés vous réagissez à nouveau je
crois que les uns et les autres veulent
que le périmètre de la primaire son
temps son organisation soit le plus
proche de ses positions à quoi ça tient
ou ça on arrivera un compromis entre
l'automne et l'hiver il y pas beau coup
y'a pas un an qui passe non bon donc on
doit pouvoir se mettre d'accord le
hausse le ton
vis-à-vis du parti socialiste n'a rien à
voir avec la primaire il a tout à voir
avec la compétition entre monsieur
pierre laurent et jean-luc mélenchon
alors jean christophe cambadélis parle
de stratégie de mesquinerie de bisbilles
entre partis c'est ça la primaire c'est
pense que jean christophe cambadélis
n'est pas du tout le ton qui l'emploie
là un peu un peu comme ça arrogant voilà
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de la
situation
la situation est grave dans le pays
elle est grave pour les gens elle est
grave parce que le gouvernement que
jusqu'à preuve du contraire monsieur
cambadélis soutien mais sur la table un
projet très inquiétant sur le code du
travail
donc jean christophe cambadélis devrait
se poser ces questions l'armée et voir
comment ils y répondent plutôt que
d'essayer de jouer comme ça celui qui
donne des leçons à tous mis l'exécutif
ni le chef du ps qui est quand même qui
reste le principal parti de gauche ne
sont vraiment d'accord comme vous dites
alors comment est ce que vous faites
organisée c'est une contradiction qui
existe dans le parti socialiste et que
moi je ne vais pas tranché à leur place
ce que je constate et c'est pour ça que
je crois ou un processus de primaires
c'est que de très très nombreux
socialistes et ça a commencé par tout ce
qu'on appelle la gauche du ps qui a
adopté une motion à l'unanimité fin
janvier alors que jean-christophe
cambadélis refusé de se prononcer pour
ce processus peut on dit banco parce
qu'il faut ré ouvrir le débat
donc moi ce que je constate et c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est que de plus en
plus de
deux socialistes est encore plus
d'électeurs socialistes de 2012 ont
envie de ce grand changement et n'ont
pas envie de retourner avec un candidat
qui a trahi toutes ses promesses à
l'élection de 2012 alors c'est ce que
l'on est ce qu'on donne de l'espace à ce
débat là est ce qu'on crée un cadre qui
va permettre à tous ces gens de dire
voilà nous les priorités que nous
voulons parce que c'est aux électeurs de
définir le mandat pao pao candidats nous
sommes quand nous présentons à des
élections nous devons rendre compte
devant les électeurs
moi je dis à tous les électeurs de
gauche qui sont dégoûtés de la situation
actuelle c'est à vous de reprendre les
affaires en main c'est à vous de vous
mêler de ce processus c'est à vous de
dire voilà quel doit être le mandat du
futur candidat qu'on aura aidée et le
candidat on trouvera s'il ya des
candidats qui n'ont pas envie de ce
mandat là eh bien ils vont faire autre
chose mais innovant et vendre aux
rameurs justement martine aubry demain
doit participer à 20 est donné
participant en tout cas une réunion des
organisateurs de cette primaire à gauche
est ce que par exemple martine aubry ce
serait quelqu'un derrière le mais je ne
parlerais pas que ce qui m'est sens un
casting avec martine aubry ses idées est
ce que vous pourriez ce que ça pourrait
correspondre
mais il y a beaucoup de choses qu'il
faudrait que je discute avec martine
aubry parce qu'on n'a pas eu les mêmes
positions ces derniers temps mais
s'était dit dans quelle qu'elle fait
partie est déjà dit plusieurs fois de
ceux qui n'ont pas partagé les choix
gouvernementaux dans la dernière dans la
dernière période tout en ayant fait des
compromis qui n'ont pas très bien marché
quand même au dernier congrès du parti
socialiste mais je le répète avant
d'être eux on aura le temps de régler le
problème de la candidature avant cela il
faut d'abord créer ces conditions là
effectivement les réunions qui se
tiennent celles qui sont organisées par
l'appel commun par les appels des
primaires celles que moi j'organise tous
les lundis au siège de notre parti qui
s'appelle les lundis de gauche
réunissent énormément de monde mais les
gens ils viennent avec plein de
questions plein de doutes plein de
méfiance ils veulent comprendre ce qui
peut se passer mais c'est normal mais
est-ce qu'on a une chance à ce débat
populaire et est ce qu on invite les
gens à avoir du pouvoir sur ce qui va se
passer
ou alors est ce qu'on leur dit vous
vous êtes des spectateurs les candidats
vont s'auto proclamer les uns après les
autres et puis vous aurez le droit de
choisir
et puis point final mais les gens ne
veulent plus que ça se passe comme ça en
politique surtout qu'ils viennent de
vivre cinq ans ou ce hoquet dans
lesquels ils avaient ils avaient donné
leur confiance ont trahi cette confiance
donc il faut construire un autre
processus est ce que le parti communiste
français est le seul en mesure
aujourd'hui matériellement je veux dire
d'organiser cette primaire que vous
appelez de vos voeux
parce que là vous avez tout dit non je
ne crois pas que nous soyons les ans
d'ailleurs dans mais je pense que
évidemment notre notre force militante
serait sera un atout indéniable parce
que nous restons un parti qui est
organisé sur tout le territoire avec des
gens qui ne sont prêts à dépenser
beaucoup de temps pour ça quand il ya
des élections normales
vous savez qu'il ya des ceux qui
tiennent les bureaux de vote sont des
employés de mairie mais aussi des
militants nous sommes présents nous dont
nous sommes capables en vous et les
milliers de bureaux donc notre force
militante compterait beaucoup mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres gens il ya un d appel
parce qu'il ya plusieurs appels aux
primaires il y en a un qui par exemple
en ce moment récole dit non veulent
organiser et qui récoltent les noms et
les adresses de gens qui sont prêts à
devenir des bénévoles de la primaire et
cet appel là ils recueillent en ce
moment des centaines et des milliers de
gens qui disent nous on veut bien être
des bénévoles de la primaire donc moi je
crois que si on organisait sa il ya
plein de citoyens d'accord elle s'amuse
de victor bout j'ai encore une question
sur qui va encore nous ramener à jean
luc mélenchon mais elle porte sur la
syrie la position pro poutine qui a
affiché ouvertement par jean luc
mélenchon est ce qu'elle vous convient
est-ce que vous la condamnée est ce que
vous estimez comme jean luc mélenchon
que c'est vladimir poutine qui va nous
libérer des djihadistes du groupe
mais moi je veux pas me prononcer par
rapport à jean luc mélenchon parce que
lui même a dit qu' on a trahi ses propos
tout ça aura sur le sujet si rien qu'en
mai sur le sujet syrien oui je pense que
poutine pas plus que d'autres grandes
puissances ne joue un rôle positif dans
cette affaire il a justement un des
drames que vit le peuple
le drame que vit le peuple syrien c'est
que ce peuple est resté l'otage de la
lutte entre ce régime qui l'a d'abord
réprimer celui de bachar el-assad le
groupe d'âge qui s'est installée dans le
chaos de la guerre mais aussi les
grandes puissances qui entoure ce pays
et qui ont toutes joué avec le feu pour
défendre leurs propres intérêts et pas
l'avenir du peuple syrien et je pense
que si un processus de paix doit se
mettre en place et il est urgent il doit
se mettre en place
on obligeant ses grandes puissances à
revenir à la table de discussion
politique et à la paix et qu'ils cessent
les uns et les autres de continuer à
noyer ce pays sous un tapis de bombes
dernière question
mais c'est peut-être les candidats de
droite qui se déclarent aujourd'hui le
nouveau candidat alors par exemple mais
jean christophe cambadélis a dit que
c'était le candidat le plus sérieux le
plus dangereux pardon à droite est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui écoutez
moi j'ai je lis les programmes des uns
et les autres j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont tous assez dangereux j'ai le les
programmes contenus dans ce qu'on sait
de françois fillon d'alain juppé et et
de nicolas sarkozy sont extrêmement
inquiétant est celui de bruno le maire
aussi malheureusement ça risque d'être
une primaire à droite on va rivaliser de
surenchère ou vers des programmes
libéraux et des programmes qui emprunte
aussi sur les questions sociétales
beaucoup aux thèmes de l'extrême droite
donc ça risque d'être une primaire
inquiétante c'est pour ça qu'on fasse il
faut que nous aussi on soit capable de
faire preuve de rassemblement merci
lucie et troisième parties de rémy sur
une troisième question qu'elle va vous
poser
michaël szames est-ce que réclamez-vous
à l'union européenne vaut 1 vous demande
donc de forcer votre nature je vivais en
vous mettant dans la forme en tout cas
dans la peau d'un david cameron qui a
donc réussi à se faire entendre des 27
pour une europe réforme et je pense que
le royaume uni serait plus fort dans une
europe réformer parce que nous pouvons
être leader d'une des plus grandes
formations du monde depuis l'intérieur
n'autorise aisée le choix est entre vos
mains
mes recommandations sont claires je
pense que le royaume uni sera plus en
sécurité
plus fort et plus riches dans une union
européenne réforme
je n'aime pas bruxelles
j'aime le royaume uni bonsoir mickaël
szames elle sans michel vincent perron
bonsoir et vous vous aimez vos selles la
ville
il ya des choses bien dans la ville mais
la commission de bruxelles et
l'orientation actuelle de l'union
européenne pas du tout donc un peu
d'ailleurs comme david cameron alors ça
ouvre à david cameron parce que ce qui
est allé demander david cameron à
bruxelles
c'est des dérogations sociales et des
libertés pour pratiquer le dumping
social un peu plus fortement dans son
nom son pays
donc moi ma conception de l'europe est
inverse c'est à dire je pense que le
défaut d'europe actuelle c'est qu'elle
ne construit pas des droits sociaux elle
ne fait pas progresser l'égalité en
europe elle organise les inégalités la
concurrence là où elle devrait faire
progresser les droits comment et les
droits sociaux vers le haut lieu a
réussi à faire un tendre le bras de
l'union européenne est-ce que vous même
ou ce que vous proposez pour
éventuellement cette horde de gauche
comme vous souhaitez vous seriez prêts
aussi à faire tendre le bras de l'union
européenne
mais il faudra le faire parce que je
pense que ça n'est pas très étonnant
parce qu'on voit bien là dit la
différence de traitement pour les
puissants comme cameron
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé avec la
grèce c'est à dire la caractéristique de
l'union européenne actuelle c'est
qu'elle est faible avec les forts et
qu'elle est très dur avec les faibles
donc cela s'est passé avec la grèce
quand même oui elle alors oui si on fait
les comptes depuis le départ on a
beaucoup plus tirée d'argent de la grèce
qu'on en a donné depuis le début de la
crise et on a fait payer au peuple grec
de manière extrêmement grave
la dette la dette des créanciers et des
banques qui s'étaient endettés sur le
dos de la grèce
est ce que vous demandez vous au 6 mai
donc l'europe est une europe où les
pauvres de nos riches pour le moment
mais pas l'envers sans contrairement à
ce qu'on nous dit tous les jours
chalmé mais moi j'ai des choses
mettre sur la table est très importante
je pense que la première chose à faire
face à la situation sociale extrêmement
inquiétante qui en europe c'est qu'il
faudrait changer immédiatement le cours
de la politique de la banque centrale
européenne stoppez les politiques
d'austérité et au contraire l'argent qui
était actuellement injectés par la
banque centrale européenne pour
renflouer les systèmes bancaires les
marchés financiers investir cet argent
dans des programmes de développement
socio- de l'europe qui permettent de
réduire les inégalités
il y à des inégalités considérables en
europe il faut les réduire il y en a à
l'intérieur des pays en a entre les pays
est il faut des programmes
d'investissement très important par
exemple dans le domaine des transports
dans le domaine du ferroviaire dans le
domaine de l'écologie dans le domaine du
logement et une seule morale des plans
juncker le logement le logement est un
problème qui se pose dans toute l'union
dans toute l'union européenne
il faudrait des programmes pour la
jeunesse mais bien plus ambitieux que le
plan du coeur on a mis les marbres
excite réa pas pour ou contre
comme les anglais le demande non mais il
faut voter non mais il faudrait que
parce que vous souhaitez vraiment de
bretagne reste dans l'union oui je
souhaiterais la grande bretagne reste
dans l'union et jeu je pense et on
risque si haut si on n'y prend pas garde
d'assister parce qu'on a voulu maintenir
ses politiques libérales à toute force
on risque d'assister à ce que l'union
européenne vole en éclats mais on va
jeter comme ça les peuples les uns
contre les autres sans avoir trouvé de
solution défis qui sont posées mais
comment est-ce que je procéderai je
pense qu'il faut que la france engage
immédiatement mettre 10 à l'union
européenne
il y à un changement politique dans
notre pays et nous nous voulons
renégocier avec avec l'union renégocier
ça prenait même prix mais c'est clair
que les premiers françois hollande en
on a vraiment volé à faire rien qui est
une grâce à vos yeux dans la politique
de prêt à renoncer à faire immédiatement
après avoir été élu mais je ferai
remarquer
sans aller aussi loin que ce que je
souhaitais c'est ce qui vient de se
passer avec le portugal personne n'en
parle je trouve ça extrêmement étonnant
parce que tout le monde parle de là
en bretagne personne ne parle de ce qui
vient de se passer au portugal il ya un
gouvernement au portugal qui est
aujourd'hui un gouvernement socialiste
qui est soutenu de manière parlementaire
par les communistes et par une autre
organisation gauche qui s'appelle le
bloco qui est membre du parti de la
gauche européenne que je préside et ils
viennent de faire de revenir aux 35
heures d'augmenter les salaires des
fonctionnaires et ils ont obtenu et ils
ont renégocié avec lui nos clubs en
allant par tuer ou moderne quoi ce
serait impossible de l'envers essayez la
france le faisait en allant voir les
portugais les espagnols les grecs et en
dix ans ensemble nous nous demandons dre
ouvrir la discussion sur ça n'allait
rien n'aura aucun poids
et quand même sur l exemple aujourd'hui
il est allé en espagne il a dit à
podemos qu'il faut désobéir à bruxelles
sas et la marche la bonne conduite des
very redire non qu'est ce que ça veut
dire désobéir à ne pas respecter les
consignes oui ça veut dire ça mais par
exemple créé par exemple compte quand
l'union européenne nous demandent de
déréglementer un peu plus ou de
privatiser un peu plus il faut lui dire
non et il faut faire la démonstration en
s'adossant à ce que ce que souhaiterait
notre peuple qu on ne fera pas ça parce
que ça a conduit à la catastrophe
regardez ce qu'on a fait sur les paysans
on a accepté de déréguler tous les prix
et on nous a expliqué qu'avec sa salle à
aller mieux et maintenant on est on est
dans une crise terrible et le ministre
de l'agriculture va à bruxelles
et il dit il a l'air d'un peu tout ça
mais on a tout accepté ce qu'il aurait
alors fusé à ce moment là alors l'europe
ce sont aussi les migrants la jungle
merkel avec 200 cloche au sein du
gouvernement sur la chancelière entre le
premier ministre et puis son
prédécesseur qui est de retour dans le
gouvernement on écoute et vous réagissez
l'europe la france et de l'allemagne ne
pourront pas accueillir tous les
réfugiés tous les demandeurs d'asile qui
viennent des conflits comme la syrie
face aux crises il faut faire preuve de
volonté et d'imagination
je pense en particulier à l'afflux
massif des réfugiés face auquel
l'allemagne et le peuple allemand
agissent avec un courage qui force le
respect des deux tiers raison alors là
en l'occurrence je suis plus proche de
ce que dit jean marc ayrault que de ce
que dit manuel valls
je pense que face au drame qui celui de
la guerre dans tout le grand moyen
orient nous dans lesquels nos propres
forces militaires sont engagés et qui
contribue à la fuite de de gens qui sont
massacrés par la guerre et qui fuient
ces conflits et donc qu'ils ont droit à
l'asile
eh bien je pense que l'europe devrait se
mobiliser toute entière'' mai mais c'est
un problème qui devrait être
effectivement traitée dans la solidarité
au plan européen est ce que vous êtes et
l'agglo l'ensemble des migrants qui le
souhaitent qu'ils soient de venir en
france est ce que vous seriez pour je
pense qu'il faut faire plusieurs choses
il faut en tout cas on accueillir
beaucoup de kilos maximum beaucoup plus
bien sûr
aujourd'hui ça serait 30000 vous
souhaitez que se sont beaucoup plus dans
la la france c'est un chiffre ridicule
ridicule pour la france et c'est un
chiffre indigne même par rapport à ce
qui se passe il y à des sans religion en
venir d'un autre pays
non mais ça c'est tu c'est une autre
question même si on nous dit qu'on va
obliger les migrants à aller dans tel ou
tel pays mais nous sommes dans une
situation qui est grave et qui
équilibrent crise' total par exemple
nous disons nous disons aux grecs au
gouvernement grec et alexis tsipras a
protesté contre cette attitude au
dernier sommet européen
on dit aux grecs vous êtes la frontière
de l'europe c'est à vous de faire la
police dans votre seul pays sur les îles
grecques etc et débrouillez vous avec le
problème
et puis à l'intérieur de l'europe pour
ferme toutes les frontières
et quand
réfugié traverse la grèce il y à des
pays qui sont juste au nord de la grèce
qui ferment leurs frontières avec
personne mourir les frontières vous
parlez de fraudeurs ce qui se passe à
calais aujourd'hui la belgique a décidé
de fermer temporairement mettant par
avocat ses frontières avec la défense
avec la france c'est la fin de schengen
mais on voit bien que cette question
elle est allée me schengen émise en
cause aujourd'hui par deux traits là
aujourd'hui on lit un constat parle je
n'ai d'abord pas et puis et puis
d'abord il ya le problème de
l'angleterre qui ferme sa frontière
parce que qu'on est dans une situation
quand même c'est l'angleterre qui ferme
sa frontière
mais qu'il la ferme et ont passé un
accord avec la france que nous avons
accepté la cena belge et de telle
manière que la frontière elle est en
france c'est eux qui ferme la frontière
mais la frontière est en france
maintenant c'est la belgique cette
attitude elle est scandaleuse parce que
face au drame de ces femmes et de ces
hommes qui ont été gelés jetés sur les
routes de l'exil par la guerre et qui
fuit dahesh que nous prétendons
nous-mêmes combattre et bien
effectivement si nous voulons traiter le
problème
il faut à l'échelle de l'europe un grand
plan d'accueil des réfugiés et il faut
le faire avec des moyens il faut
construire des centres d'accueil dans
dans les différents pays mais il faut un
plan européen pour ça et et arrêter de
se jeter c'est de jeter sur les routes
de l'exil
ces pauvres malheureux d'un pays à
l'autre on va terminer les missions en
revenant sur le parti communiste
français et sur vos également si vous
êtes d'accord
on peut pas dire que le parti communiste
est enregistré de bons résultats
électoraux
ces dernières années on écoute ce qu'en
dit pascal perrineau rencontre il ya
quelques instants par et stéphane à
magnan et vous réagissez
ça fait longtemps que le parti
communisme qui a connu une forte
décroissance électorale n'a plus
beaucoup de capacité à se faire entendre
par le mouvement social par la société
française
c'était déjà le cas avec madame buffet
qui a qui étaient avant à la tête
également du parti communiste donc le
processus est un processus anciens c'est
le parti communiste en tant que tel le
message même du communisme aujourd'hui
qui ne parle plus beaucoup à la société
française et la faiblesse relative de
monsieur laurent la tête du parti
communiste et la faiblesse du communisme
en france et pas simplement la faiblesse
de monsieur perlant alors les faiblesses
à plusieurs niveaux donc si on écoute
pascal perrineau
vous avez dit récemment qu'il faudrait
que monsieur perrineau change de 10
parce qu'il ça fait longtemps lui ça
fait longtemps qu'il dit la même chose
et si vous voulez regarder d'un peu plus
près la réalité du parti communiste le
renouvellement de générations qu'il
traverse
ce qui est en train de se passer dans le
parti communiste et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui à gauche le parti qui est
le plus le plus dynamique et le plus
présent sur le terrain y compris que ces
forces militantes celle parti communiste
en moins ça fait mal parce que les verts
il ya le parti socialiste n'a qu'à
regarder leurs états à gauche et acquis
aujourd'hui
alors peut-être que le parti communiste
il a beaucoup de choses à changer c'est
le procès chose que je pense qu'on fait
un congrès et on va à nouveau changer
des choses et améliorer notre projet
mais s'il ya un parti sur laquelle la
gauche peu con sur lequel la gauche peut
compter aujourd'hui c'est le parti
communiste
donc si on veut regarder un peu puisque
monsieur perrineau dit depuis longtemps
et c'est terrab ce qui s'est passé
depuis longtemps c'est que aujourd'hui
justement dans une crise que traverse
l'ensemble de la gauche il ya une force
sur laquelle on peut compter c'est le
parti communiquer à leurs hommes pour
porter ces idées faut aussi une personne
et c'est vous et vous avez dit récemment
que
il faut forcer votre nature quand on
veut devenir un personnage public et
médiatique
c'est par devoir que vous le faites pas
rom non mais c'est moi j'aime beaucoup
ce que je fais et j'adore j'adore la
politique et j'adore la politique de
proximité et ce que j'ai dit dans
l'interview auquel vous faites allusion
aux aidants libéralisme je n'aime pas je
n'aime pas le pouvoir personnel et je
mens messi et je trouve que pour un
communiste est d'ailleurs d'une manière
générale pour quelqu'un qui fait de la
politique c'est plutôt une qualité de se
méfier du pouvoir personnel
alors c'est vrai que nous vivons dans
une vie politique et médiatique qui
personnalise tout et de ce point de vue
je dis oui je force ma nature parce que
moi je crois davantage et encore avoir
de la mare davantage au collectif au
travail collectif que à la mise en scène
personnelle et je pense que s'il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans notre
vie démocratique c'est précisément ça
parce qu'une des choses il faudrait la
vie politique française oui c'est la
mise en scène présidentielle permanente
par exemple michael connelly pauline la
metteur en scène pour nous est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
qu'elle vous pourriez songé mais quand
vous êtes effectivement quand vous êtes
obligés de vous mettre en scène et que
vous êtes présents eh ben vous faites
conseiller c'est tout c'est vous le fait
mal vous le faites pas seulement
mais moi aussi je conseille de ce type
parce qu'il faut le faire apprendre à
parler du metteur en scène
c'est dans les médias il faut faire des
choses comme ça et je n'ai pas du tout
ronde de ça ça n'est pas le problème
mais en même temps que je fais ça et je
ne suis déjà plus même par rapport à ce
que j' étais quand je suis devenu
secrétaire national du parti communiste
et je ne vais cesser de m'améliorer je
vous rassure
voilà des mais en même temps qu'ils que
je fais ça c'est vrai que moi j'alerte
les citoyens auxquels je m'adresse vos
téléspectateurs et je le redis je le
redis ne vous laissez pas abuser par
toutes ces mises en scène par ce que
croyait davantage en votre force
collective et croyait davantage on la
sincérité et en la proximité de travail
des hommes politiques quand leur mise en
scène médiatique et jeu et en disant ça
je pense que je rends service à la
démocratie et vous lâchez les coûts de
l'émission on l'a entendu notamment dans
la première partie vous fondez l'armure
c'est ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui est
ce que vous êtes définitivement
candidats à la primaire non je ne suis
pas définitivement candidats puisque je
n'ai pas encore déclarée une candidature
de ce qu'est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui quand non mais si jamais un
processus collectif ce que j'ai dit et
je le redis avant la session en asie un
processus collectif se met en place les
communistes pas pierre leurrons pas ce
que ça ne sera pas une décision
personnelle non les communistes auront à
se poser une question à ce moment là
est-ce qu'il soutienne un candidat ce
qu'ils on présente à ce moment là on se
posera cette question mais d'abord il
faut travailler
est ce que vous avez envie mais moi j'ai
envie de représenter mes idées sinon je
serais pas secrétaire nationale du parti
communiste y aller donc j'ai forcément
envie que mes idées soit présente dans
le débat qu'elle soit défendu qu'elles
soient défendues mais je ne suis pas le
sol non plus à pouvoir les accords on
attendra on attendra oui je sais bien
que ça de la bonne réponse vous sélectif
ça vous ça vous dérange parce que c'est
des il ya des codes et vous vous pensez
que c'est forcément obligé de passer par
c'est qu'au delà pour être efficace tout
ça alors on attend de voir je crois ce
que je dis c'est à dire le collectif
d'abord ok pour décider ce genre de
champ d'atora merci merci merci à tous
bon soir la semaine prochaine nous
serons au salon de l'agriculture bonsoir
qui